we start off with a barbified Warner
Brothers emblem then we get a glimpse of
the beautiful Barbie land perfectly
protected by a heart and a pink airplane
flying over it I will know it's not the
toy Barbie airplane I have bought that
for my niece that thing's more like a
cargo jet it's got a great view of the
beach and all that inhabitants The
Umbrellas resemble the one from Barbie's
Glam Pool we got an ice cream shop that
genuinely looks like Barbie's soda shop
but back in the day Melody with the
Barbie ice cream truck set and a roller
disco along with a disco 59 club we know
Barbies love to party don't we
I also love that this place is so
plastic the Barbie doesn't really leave
Footprints in the Sand if you only see
Zero sets of footprints in the sand it's
because we're freaking flying baby that
water doesn't even move the flags look
like a Swain in the wind but they're not
everything is plastic wrapped in plastic
it's fantastic oh my God just like me
foreign